clowns I did go to clown college yeah
and my father was a ringleader at the
circus nice which circus oh the Dell
pickle Family Circus nice I think of
myself as a modern clown as well in a
lot of guys very clown-like you know
yeah big suits ridiculous stuff I mean
it's a different version of a clown
there's different types of clowns you
know I mean dude I love I love what you
do I love the way that it's legit music
but you're having a laugh I think
there's enough people trying to be cool
and I feel like Cool's been played out
since James Dean I don't really need to
cover that that's not really that
interesting from an artistic standpoint
because when you're an artist everything
you do is Art you know when you go to a
high level Michelin star Chef that's art
obviously but when you get someone who
makes a great McDonald's burger that's
art so as an artist my duty is whatever
I do if I'm gonna do an interview that
can't just be a means to an end for
press it needs to be an art piece